Okay. Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Herr Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Heimrich Hiedmar.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Ja.
H-I-N-R-I-C-A.
Heinrich.
Ja.
T-H-I-T-M-A-R. Tiedmar.
A-R. Richtig?
Ja. Ja. Ja.
Okay. Herr Tiedmar, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt, Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 8. Juni 1972.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 78.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
73 Kilogramm.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen. Herr Tiedmar, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja Doktor, ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Etwa 45 Minuten, ja.
Okay. Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen? Ich meine Oberbauch, Unterbauch?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind im Oberbauch, ja Doktor.
Und im Mittelfen oder rechten Seite, linken Seite?
Ich habe ganz Oberbauchschmerzen, aber die Schmerzen strahlen die rechte Oberbauchseite aus, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Tiedmar, können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind Sie eher drückend, dummstechend?
Ja Doktor, die Schmerzen sind krankartig, ja.
Okay. Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen sie auch wieder weg? Ich meine, ist das wellenförmig?
Ja, wellenförmig, ja.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen treten plötzlich auf, ja.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichten und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich denke, dass die Schmerzen 9 sind, ja Doktor.
Okay. Herr Tiedmar, das sind sehr starke Schmerzen.
Soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Nein Doktor, ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen. Es wäre besser, wenn Sie mir ein Schmerzmittel geben können, ja.
Ja, gerne. Herr Tiedmar, ich möchte wissen, ob Sie eine Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente haben?
Medikamente? Nein.
Okay. Frau Müller, bitte geben Sie den Patienten ein Schmerzmittel.
Herr Tiedmar, wir haben Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel gegeben, ich meine eine Spasmolytika, ein Krampflöser, gegeben.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt besser?
Ja, ich fühle mich jetzt besser Doktor, danke schön.
Okay, gerne. Bitte sagen Sie mir sofort Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Schmerzmittel benötigen, okay?
Ja, danke.
Okay. Herr Tiedmar, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlimmert?
Ja Doktor, heute Morgen habe ich gut gegessen und kurz nach dem Essen haben die Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen.
Außerdem habe ich in letzter Zeit nicht gut gegessen.
Herr Tiedmar, was haben Sie zum Frühstück gegessen? Erinnern Sie sich?
Ja, ich habe einen Toast gemacht mit Butter und Tomaten, aber ich habe sehr fettige Toast gegessen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Und die Schmerzen sind nach dem Frühstück aufgetreten, richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Okay, hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, aber ich habe gesagt, in letzter Zeit vertrete ich fettiges Essen, generell nicht gut, Doktor.
Okay, waren Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, nein.
Okay, haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe Ihnen gesagt, seit etwa 45 Minuten habe ich diese Schmerzen, Doktor.
Genau, Sie haben recht. Herr Tiedmar, haben Sie eine Hautfarbeveränderung bemerkt, wie zum Beispiel Gelbsucht?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht bemerkt.
Leiden Sie unter Juckreiz?
Nein.
Okay, Herr Tiedmar, darf ich fragen, also leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen oder haben Sie ein Engelgefühl in der Brust?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein, Doktor, oder Engelgefühl, nein.
Das freut mich, okay. Leiden Sie unter Herzschmerzen, Luftnot oder Husten?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht bemerkt.
Okay, Herr Tiedmar, haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Schüttelfrost, nein, ich habe sie nicht bemerkt, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, Doktor, nein.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja, ja. Zudem habe ich Übelkeit, aber keine Erbrechen.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Nachdem diese Beschwerden habe ich nicht guten Appetit.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich denke, ich bin immer gleichgewicht.
Das freut mich, okay. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen? Ja, ich habe keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Aber Sie haben Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe häufige Verstopfungen, aber es ist lange. Dafür nehme ich zweimal pro Woche Movicol.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ich habe sehr lange Zeit Schlaflosigkeit, Doktor.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Einzuschlafen. Seit langem Jahr?
Ja, langem Jahr.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein, oder?
Ich habe von DM eine Medikament gekauft, die heißt Valdiran.
Ich nehme diese Medikament bei mir.
Okay. Alles klar. Sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, mein Impfungsstatus ist vollständig, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Tietmar, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck, Doktor.
Seit wann?
Seit vier Jahren.
Nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Ja, ich nehme Kandesartan ein. Einmal morgens.
Morgen.
Kennen Sie die Dosisierung?
Ja, nein. Ich kann es nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Medikamentliste dabei?
Ja, ja. Richtig.
Haben Sie?
Nein, nicht. Aber in meinen Häusern.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin, Herr Tietmar?
Meine Hausärztin ist Frau Schmidt.
Okay. Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Ich werde Ihre Hausärztin kontaktieren.
Danke schön.
Okay. Gern. Sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe auch schon Cholesterinwerte.
Seit wann leiden Sie?
Seit fünf Jahren. Nehme ich 20 mg Simulostatin ab und zu ein.
Okay. Ja. Sonst noch?
Ja, ich hatte früher einen Bandscheibenvorfall, den ich mit Finalgoncalbe behandle.
In welchem Bereich? Lendenbereich oder Halsbereich?
Linke. Linke Rückenbereich. Ja.
Und seit wann haben Sie dieses Problem?
Seit acht Jahren.
Okay. Und Sie benutzen Finalgoncalbe bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig?
Bei Bedarf, ja. Bei Bedarf, ja.
Okay. Das war's oder?
Das war ja.
Okay. Herr Tietmar, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf noch andere Medikamente außer genannten ein?
Ich habe keine. Ich nehme keine andere Medikamente ein, Doktor.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja. Ich wurde vor einigen Jahren in einem Nabelbruch operiert, Doktor.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Ja. Und habe auch eine Fußoperation wegen Arthrose hinter mir.
Hüftoperation, haben Sie gesagt?
Fußoperation.
Okay. Welche sagen Sie?
Arthrose. Begenarthrose, ja.
Welche Seite?
Rechts. Rechts Seite.
Okay. Alles klar. Sonst noch etwas oder das war's?
Das war's. Das war's.
Okay. Herr Tietmar, sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Ja. Ich habe eine bekannte Fruchtzuckerunfertiglichkeit, ja.
Wie äußert sich diese Unfertiglichkeit?
Das äußert sich mit Beläungen und Verdunstproblemen, ja.
Durch Schwal meinen Sie?
Ja, manchmal ja.
Okay.
Außerdem habe ich eine Kreuzallergie gegen Äpfel und Birkenpollen, Doktor.
Und wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, das äußert sich bei mir.
Schnupfen, Bauchschmerzen, Hautausschlag und Yukreis.
Okay. Herr Tietmar, rauchen Sie?
Ja. Ich rauche seit meinem 17. Leben ja, Doktor.
Wie viel rauchen Sie?
Ja. Etwa 15 Zigaretten pro Tag, ja.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, trinke etwa zwei bis drei Mal pro Woche Wein.
Aber ich habe eine Frage stellen.
Ja, bitteschön.
Ja, ich habe mit meiner Nachbarin gehört, Wein ist gut für mein Herz. Ist das richtig oder falsch?
Also die Menge von Wein ist sehr wichtig, Herr Tietmar.
Also weniger unregelmäßiger Alkoholkonsum kann ein bisschen gut für Ihre Gesundheit sein.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zwei bis drei Mal Wein pro Woche trinken.
Ja.
Ist das ein Glas oder?
Ja, zwei bis drei Glas. Glas ist für mich oder nicht gut.
Das ist kein Problem bei uns, ja?
Ja.
Herr Tietmar, okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen habe ich nicht genommen, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Herr Tietmar, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Brüthochtruck?
Mein Vater ist mit sechs oder sieben Jahren an Bauchspezif-Dürsenkrebs gestorben.
Mein Beileid, Herr Tietmar. Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat eine Schwäche. Sie lebt in Altenheim.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich bin ein Kind, Doktor.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Familienstand? Ich bin verheiratet, aber getrennt.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Erwachsene, gesunde Kinder.
Okay. Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich bin allein. Ich wohne allein, ja.
Okay. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Bürokaufmann.
Sind Sie zufrieden bei der Arbeit?
Ich habe viel Stress, Doktor. Meine Kollegin oder Kollegen.
Oder andere Probleme, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Das kann manchmal schwer sein, ne?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Herr Tietmar, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor. Was habe ich? Ich habe Schmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Herr Tietmar. Es ist zu früh, etwas genauer zu sagen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie eine Gallenblase Steine haben.
Aber zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Ja, alle, also sobald die alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen, okay?
Okay. Bleibe ich in Krankenhaus, Doktor?
Ja, ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können und eine Therapie einleiten können.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen, ja?
Doktor, legen Sie mir einen intravenösen Zugang oder eine Paraphyllans mit Nadal?
Okay, Herr Tietmar, das ist eine sehr einfache Untersuchung. Sie werden nur einen kurzen, leichten Stichgefühl.
Ja, aber wir müssen diesen Venusenzugang legen. Also wir werden Ihnen Blut abnehmen und wenn nötig andere Medikamente verabreichen, ja?
Gibt es keine Alternative, oder?
Leider nicht. Aber wir können eine lokale Betäubung geben, wenn Sie benötigen, ja?
Das wäre besser, danke schön, Doktor. Ich würde auch gerne.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da, ja?
Danke schön.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberhausen. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Heinrich Tietmar ist 53 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß und 73 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Tietmar stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 45 Minuten bestehender Füße- und Oberbauchschmerzen vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien krampfartig, wellenformig und würden in den rechten Oberbauch ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzskala mit 9 von 10 bewertet und der Patient habe gegen diese Schmerzen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Frühstück aufgetreten seien.
Der Patient habe zum Frühstück fettiges Essen gegessen und er habe über eine Empfindlichkeit mit fettigem Essen gegessen.
Die Fragen nach Icterus, Pulitus, Angina Pectoris, Trachicardi, Dyspne und Fieber wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgen dem bekannt.
Nach der Obstration der Schmerzen wurde die Schmerzbedingte Inapetenz nach der Nausea ohne Emesis enthalten.
Der Patient nehme dagegen Movicol zweimal pro Woche ein und seit Langem bestehende Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen.
Der Patient nehme dagegen Baldrian bei Bedarf ein.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Vor Erkrankungen nannte er seit vier Jahren bestehende arterielle Hypertonie, seit fünf Jahren bestehende Hyperkolestrinämie und seit acht Jahren bestehende Discus prolaps im Lendenbereich.
Er nehme Kandesatan morgens, Zingva-Statin 20 mg abends ein.
Die Dosierung von Kandesatan sollte geklärt werden und der Patient benutze Finalgon Salbe gegen Discus prolaps bei Bedarf.
Vor einigen Jahren sei er an einer Hernia umlichalis operiert worden und er sei an einer Arthrose im rechten Fuß operiert worden.
Er habe Kreuzallergie gegen Abfall und Birkenpollen.
Diese Allergie äußert sich durch Abdominalschmerzen, Puri-Tus und Exanthem.
Er habe Fructoseintoleranz, die sich durch Meteorismus und Diarrhea und andere Verdauungsprobleme äußert.
Er sei Raucher und er rauchte seit dem 17. Lebensjahr 15 Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinke zwei bis drei mal ein Glas Wein pro Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass die Mutter an Herzinsuffizienz leide und sie lebe in einem Altenheim.
Der Vater sei mit 76 Jahren an Pankreas carcinom verstorben.
Der Patient sei Einzelkind verheiratet, aber getrennt.
Er habe gesunde zwei Kinder und wohne alleine.
Er sei Bürokaufmann von Beruf und habe viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Scholesistolitis aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter rechtsseitige Oberbauchschmerzen, krampfartige, wellenförmige Schmerzen.
Diese Symptome sprechen und die Schmerzen seien nach dem fettiges Essen aufgetreten.
Die Symptome sprechen für eine Scholesistolitis.
Als die Franzisdiagnosen kommen, Scholesistitis, Scholedokalitis, Nepholitis, Urolitis in Betracht.
Wir sollen auch Myokatinfakt als Differenzdiagnose ausschließen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, Murphy-Zeichen, Abwehrspannung, Loslassschmerzen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Bilirubinwerte, Amylase, Lipase, Herzenzyme, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine EKG schreiben, um den Myokatinfakt auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgen des Abdomens durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel gallen Blasensteine, zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Abdominalzoonographie veranlassen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT des Abdomens durchführen und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine RCP durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen und gleichzeitig die Steine zu entfernen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientestation aufnehmen und ich würde bei den Patienten einen Venüsuzugang legen.
Danach würde ich Analgetikum, Antiemetikum, Spasmodetikum verbreiten.
Ich würde ein chirurgisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberanzt.
Herr Kollegen, denken Sie in diesem Fall als Differentialdiagnose Akutkolesistitis?
Akutkolesistitis kommt auf jeden Fall als Differentialdiagnose, aber es gibt keine Fieber bei diesen Patienten, deswegen meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Scholesistolythiasis.
Haben Sie eine Vermutung, wo der Stein ist? Im Gallenblase? Dr. Sistikus oder Dr. Koledokus?
Ich denke, dass der Stein im Gallenblase ist, Herr Oberanzt.
Wenn der Stein im Gallenblase ist, welche therapeutische Maßnahme empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Wenn die Menge von Steinen im Gallenblase zu viel ist, können wir eine Cholesistektomie empfehlen.
Oder wenn die Zahl der Steine im Gallenblase zu wenig ist, können wir eine ESWL empfehlen, um die Steine in kleine Fragmente zu zerstören.
Sollte ich keine Antibiotika verschreiben, aber auf jeden Fall sollen wir Analgetikum, Spasmodetikum und Antimethylamin verabreichen.
Ich meine Gegenstein.
Jetzt habe ich Sie verstanden. Es gibt einige Medikamente für die Therapie im Gallenblase, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich werde es nach der Prüfung recherchieren.
Wenn der Stein unter 1 cm ist, würden wir Ursodeoxycolyk Säure empfehlen.
Wenn der Stein über 1 cm ESWL, RRCP oder Cholesistektomie ist, sind möglich.
Herr Kollegen, welche Erfindung erwarten Sie auf die Obdommenzonographie?
Wir können eine Gallenblasenwandverdickung in der Ultraschalluntersuchung und wir können auch die Steine schatten.
Wenn es eine Obstruktion im Koledokus gibt, können wir eine Erweiterung des Koledokus feststellen.
Gibt es bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besondere Zeichen?
Murphy-Zeichen ist sehr typisch bei diesem Fall.
Wir palpieren den rechtseitigen Oberbauch unterhalb des Rippens und sagen dem Patienten, tief einzuatmen.
Es gibt Schmerzen beim Tief einatmen. Das bedeutet, dass der Murphy-Zeichen positiv ist.
Welche Komplikationen verursacht Kohle-Lithiasis?
Kohle-Lithiasis ist eine Obstruktion. Wir können Hysterus, Generalisipulitis und Pancreatitis sehen.
Kohle-Lithiasis?
Kohle-Lithiasis, Herr Oberz, ich meine Kohle-Lithiasis. Wir können Prosellen.
Kohle-Lithiasis, Herr Oberz sagt Kohle-Lithiasis.
Sie meinen das. Okay, richtig.
Ist es möglich, Ileus?
Ich meine, wenn es eine Perforation gibt, ist das ein großes Problem für uns.
Aber Ileus? Keine Ahnung, Herr Oberz.
Ist es möglich, viele Gallensteine im Dickdarm bleiben.
Es verursacht Ileus.
Okay, danke für die Informationen, Herr Oberz.
Wenn der Stein im Kolodok ist, welche theoretische Maßnahme empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Ich würde RACP empfehlen, um den Stein zu entfernen.
Können Sie uns RACP aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über RACP aufklären.
RACP ist die endoskopische retrograde cholangiopancreatikografie.
Das ist die endoskopische Untersuchung der Gallengänge und des Pancreasgangs.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Steine, Entzündungen, Verletzungen, Tore und andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung schieben wir einen dünnen flexiblen optischen Schlauch durch den Mund bis in den Zwölfingerdarm vor.
Der Magen und Zwölfingerdarm müssen leer sein.
Deswegen soll der Patient sechs Stunden vor der Untersuchung nicht mehr essen oder trinken.
Dann verabreichen wir ein Kontrastmittel, um die Gallengänge und Pancreasgangs sichtbar zu machen.
Gleichzeitig können wir die Probleme feststellen und die Behandlung durchführen.
Diese Untersuchung kann sowohl zu diagnostischen als auch zu therapeutischen Zwecken benutzt werden.
Die Untersuchung dauert ca. 30-60 Minuten.
Es gibt einige Komplikationen wie Nachblutungen oder kleine Verletzungen der Schleimhäute.
Es gibt auch Kontrastmittel allergie.
Gibt es andere Komplikationen? Wichtige Komplikationen?
Wir können auch eine Pancreatitis verursachen während der Untersuchung.
Lebensschliffveränderungen sind wichtig, um bei den Patienten fettiges Essen zu vermeiden.
Auch Rauchen aufzuhören oder mindestens reduzieren.
Vielleicht auch Alkoholkonsum reduzieren.
Fettarme essen?
Ja.
Okay, Herr Kollegen, ich habe alle Fragen gestellt. Bitte gehen Sie auf unser eFodis und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg in Ihrem Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt, Sie sind sehr nett. Danke schön.